سيتوقف الليل عشرات الاف من عمال السكاكيه
الحديديه في عموم المملكه المتحده عن
العمل في اضراب يستهدف تحسين ظروف العمل
وزياده الاجور وقد تم تحذير ركوب القطارات
من حدوث مزيدا من الاضراب بالتزامن مع
اعياد الميلاد ويقول المضربون انه نصف
خطوط السكاكين الحديديه ستغلق كما ان
القطارات في معظم اسكتلندا ويلز تتوقف عن
العمل ودعت نقابه سائقه القطارات السلف
الى اضراب يوم الخامس من يناير المقبل
تزامنا مع اضرابات لقطاعات الاخرى داخله
شبكات السكاكين الحديثه
هذا وكاله نقابه التمريض قد اعلنت عن
اضراب جديد يوميه 18 وال 19 من الشهر
المقبل وادعت هيئه خدمات الصحه الوطنيه
وزاره الصحه الى الدخول في مفاوضات جاده
مع النقابات ودون تاخير واقله الهيارين
اعلانا قطاع التمريض عن موعدين اضافيين
للاضراب الشهر المقبل سيزيد الضغط على
الخدمات الصحيه المنهكه بالفعل بعد
الاضرابات الاخيره التي تنفذها طواقيم
التمريض والاسعاف واتى بعط الهيئه انه تم
اعاده جدوله الاف المواعيد او الغائها
بالكامل بسبب هذه الهجره
وقد استعانه سلطات البريطانيه بقوات من
الجيش للقيام بعمل موظفي الجوازات في
ثمانيه مطارات اضافه الى قطاعات اخرى تشهد
اضرابات من العاملين فيها
رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه كان قد اعرب عن
استيائه مما وصفه بالفوضى التي سببها موجه
لضربات الحاليه في البلاد مؤكدا ان بابه
مفتوح للمناقشات مع النقابات المنظمه
للاضرابات واضاف هناك من الحكومه تصرفت
بينزاهه ومعقوليه فيما يتعلق بالقطاع
العام وانها تريد دائما التحدث الى الناس
واشراقهم في الحوارات كي تتاكد ان وظائفهم
مرضيه ومجزيه وقد وصف الاوضاع بالصابه
وقال ان افضل ما يمكن القيام به لمصلحه
البلاد هو محاربه التضخم